japan says north korea has fired two
ballistic missiles they were launched
from south hamgyong province
into the sea near japan the u.s pacific
command has responded saying the
launches show that pyongyang is a threat
to its neighbors rob mcbride joins us
live now from the south korean capital
seoul
rob so yet another missile launch from
north korea what more do we know at this
stage
it is quite a significant development it
happened
early thursday morning was first
detected by the japanese coast guard
later confirmed by officials here in
south korea as being two projectiles
flying some
450 kilometers and both japanese and u.s
officials are now saying that these were
ballistic missiles
now this is the first time in a year
that north korea has
launched one of these provocative type
of tests
for the past couple of years since the
negotiations between north korea and the
u.s over denuclearization broke down it
has returned
to developing and testing its missiles
and weapon systems but they have tended
to be
less provocative shorter range missiles
and rockets being fired off its coast
the kind of weapons
that are not banned by un resolutions
and in fact only last weekend it was
confirmed that they had fired off
two cruise type missiles the white house
has largely
ignored that u.s president joe biden
saying that that was
no big deal that it was business as
usual
ballistic missiles are a lot harder to
ignore we have also had
this condemnation from the japanese
prime minister
yoshihide
it is a threat to our country and to
regional security
it's also a violation of the united
nations security council resolution
we'll strictly protest and condemn their
actions
i'm determined to closely cooperate with
the united states south korea
and other related nations to protect the
lives of our people
and rob the timing is significant isn't
it with senior u.s diplomats recently
visiting asia to formulate policy on
north korea
that's right we have a change in u.s
administration anthony blinken the u.s
secretary of state was in
northeast asia meeting with his
counterparts in japan south korea just
last week as they
are formulating what their strategy will
be towards north korea now the north
koreans confirmed
during that visit that they had received
overtures from u.s officials about
restarting dialogue which they
said they basically ignored and it but
it was thought by other statements that
they
would wait and see just what the policy
was not carry out any kind of
provocations
while the u.s comes up with whatever
their strategy is
it seems by this test that possibly
north korea has had a change of heart it
sees
no point in waiting possibly it has
nothing
to lose by firing off these kind of
missiles at this point and if anything
might add pressure and discomfort on the
u.s
administration all right rob mcbride
live for us there in seoul rob
thank you